your
sort of uh company barefoot athletics
yeah
uh b-e-a-r and the tagline is optimizing
the human
to ground interface we've talked about
this a little bit
with the power lifting how do you think
about
the the foot ground interface
it's interesting that we know
that we should train all these parts of
our body to be able to be stronger
be more resilient like
but we think that the foot is different
that we need to package it and modify it
and somehow that that's the science of
making
you know it healthy um where i challenge
people
think about that like first thing you do
in the morning is
roll out of bed and put your
weightlifting belt on and wrap it on
tight and wear it till you go to bed at
night do it with your shoulders your
knees
wake up and put some knee wraps on okay
and elbow wraps
and see what happens one you'll get
weaker
you'll lose movement capacity and you'll
start affecting other areas of the body
very negatively because they will start
picking up the compensation
for those joints that are not moving
properly
this is it what shoes are for
is to protect you from the environment
from cuts and abrasions
and heat and things like that but the
foot
let me the mind blowing is like every
other area of the body you need to use
it
and you need to strengthen it and you
need to learn to control it
that's it that's all i have to say about
the subject okay
it's that simple but somehow we have
been sold entire industries like the
orthotics industry
it's completely false meta-analysis of
the data shows that orthotics do nothing
beyond temporary relief
from pain over a six eight week period
of time and provide no long-term benefit
and i can't tell you how many people
i've eliminated back or knee or hip pain
from getting from working on
strengthening and controlling the foot
and ankle complex
we believe we've villainized and said a
low arch
is a condition that needs fixed
like when it really is just controlling
the foot and ankle complex and how they
relate to each other and how we use that
is it like
go put on boxing gloves in the morning
and do that for the next 20 years and
see what happens
it's not about finding the right shoe
that fits because your foot has been
deformed
and so i'm not like some wacky like oh
you got to be barefoot forever do this
like no i'm just saying
go spend some time using it strengthen
it
learn to control it and you will work
better in a shoe but
the whole running shoe movement with the
raised heel that was
the person that that suggested that that
in
to nike way back when they were trying
to figure out what to do
the reason and he says it's it's the
worst thing that he ever did
um because we were coming from an
era of people wearing healed shoes which
by the way came from um
stirrups way back in the day that's
where the whole heel came from is to go
into stirrup but then it went into
fashion and then
the running craze started coming around
in the 70s
they're uh they're starting to push this
the general mass population and they
realize that they were causing
injuries and like what are we gonna do
well that's because everybody was in
this position
and had a shortened uh shortened calf
muscle it's like well the work around
let's just put a heel on it so we don't
injure them
that's it and now because the raised
heel you gotta raise the toe and then
now with that if you go stand on
something and pull your inner toe in
and uh in a squat position just reach
down and do it you'll see that you have
no control
over the internal and external rotation
of your of of your leg
you don't and or your foot and you
actually have to put a support in
for the arch to be able to passively
control those structures
it's just band-aid on top of band-aid on
top of band-aid
use it strengthen it if you want to wear
some shoes because they look good or
fancy i'm like i have no problem i mean
i got a wife my wife will put on some
high heels every now and again
like but all i'm saying is use your foot
my thousand pound squat my thousand
pound deadlift we're done barefoot i'm
not trying to sell you shoes
go do it with no shoe that's what i've
been promoting
i did that for six years and i promoted
it but people ask me like
well what do i do because my gym
requires shoes
okay where do i go and uh and then i go
well
you know you could pick up these uh
other finger shoes or whatever and they
go man
my wife won't have sex with me and i go
i know
mine either like trust me i'm not making
this up
everybody in that market markets to one
segment and they're still missing some
gaps
because they they still have a little
bit too narrow of a toe box and with
your lifting you have the opportunity to
really get that splay and start working
on this stuff better
so i just wanted to create a shoe these
ones are odd colored because it's a
partnership with kabuki
normally we've got a black or a gray low
top high top
sticks to the ground for lifting so we
can do that and very
pliable it's a moccasin it's a
modern-day moccasin
but looks okay that you can wear it
around in other areas if you if you so
choose like
you know what the number one healthcare
cost in america is
what's that diabetes
uh heart disease cancer
[Music]
low back pain hmm
what do you attribute a little bit into
well it's attributed to a lot of things
um but inability to control spinal
position
um which starts happening from uh some
breathing issues
uh it also happens from the foot um so
there's a lot of stuff but
everything that i do actually focus on
improving this yeah
so that and it all starts with this is
one thing like this doesn't affect
breathing but um
so it does actually affect breathing to
some elections and spinal stabilization
so
the raised heel and toe will make you
stride further
because of just how it operates but that
over stride
is a result of opening this so we opened
the pelvis and diaphragm did we talk
about that and the impact that that has
for controlling and spine yeah i think
we touched on that yeah
um but it it's all this stuff plays
together so the gate affects that and so
the shoe affects the gate and then so
it's all
connected all connected let me be very
purposeful with some conversation here
though we've talked about periodization
this was a big gap so um people go yeah
well when people started running with
those they started having injuries
back when uh the finger company produced
those and didn't do the education around
this very simple concept
you do not walk into the gym if you
haven't squatted and start squatting 225
from
for max rex every week day or every day
over day
yeah and that's what people did because
they did weren't told that
you need to build the capacity to do
this
you go wear these and walk around in
your office or wherever all day long
your feet are gonna hurt
they're gonna be sore do it for 10
of your time yeah do that for a month
then add some that will build the
capacity to do this and then that's
going to start having
the ability to strength and manage the
foot there's a whole lot of other stuff
i've got videos on
things that you can do buy whatever you
want or just
just spend some time out of them like
that's all that i want people to do
because it is so simple
and it has such a profound impact yeah
it does i
what i did uh i noticed when you walked
uh when i walked in i was like oh hey
you're spending some time without the
last shoes on
uh well what i did um i think it's
already now two years ago when i was
doing a lot of running
i do like a 10 mile run i would take my
shoes off for the last like half mile
and i run like that and that was for me
really helpful
to ensure that i have proper form form
that minimizes pain on the way i run
i still like shoes i benefit a lot from
shoes the protection they provide but
it's for running we're referring to
especially trail lining and so on and in
the city when there's glass and all
those kinds of things
but it's really important to have
minimal sort of protection on your feet
for me at least it was to figure out
the ways that my form basic movement
and like the positioning in the foot the
impact of the foot
and everything you know the the the
lower leg
like the entirety of the torso really
how it's
improperly positioned in terms for the
objective of minimizing pain and the
barefoot running really helped uh fix
that for me
because i figure out that i need to take
uh shorter uh steps
uh more frequent you know all those
kinds of things and that really helps
you figure that out
like let's be realist about stuff like
um
spend some time using it strengthen it
and i've got some great ways to to do
that and learn how to do that so
you